christopher maloney and mariska hargitay
just teased law and order svu fans with
a steamy behind the scenes pick and we
are not okay my focus has always been
the quality of the show it all started
over the weekend when a twitter user
posted a few snaps of the actors on set
portraying their iconic characters
detectives elliott stabler and olivia
benson in the middle of a passionate
kissing scene the fan added quote can
y'all imagine if one day christopher and
mariska post a picture like this
pretending they are kissing with the
caption hashtag rehearsing it would be
the end of us and the end of the
internet well it didn't take long for
christopher and mariska to take note and
they gave fans who desperately want to
see their characters end up together a
little gift chris snapped this pic with
his co-star staring into each other's
eyes seemingly about to lock lips
writing quote
rehearsing what mariska it's almost
pavlovian just to see the reaction
mariska retweeted all that adding quote
are you blushing it's getting hot in
here along with a fire emoji and yes yes
it is getting hot in here this is very
exciting needless to say fans flooded
the replies of the post to totally swoon
over the pic and back in 2020
christopher totally swooned over his
longtime friend during a chat with et
you guys have been friends for what 20
years plus something like that what does
this friendship mean to you wherever we
are in our careers right now
we were born together in that moment you
know i know she had
a lot of great work before svu i had a
lot of great jobs a lot of great work
before svu
but you know that kind of inextricably
linked and connected in that way and
beyond that we're very good friends i
think we value each other you know we
just pick it up right where we left off
and she doesn't have this relationship
with anyone else i can guarantee you and
i don't have a relationship like that i
have with her with anyone else so it's
unique it's full of laughter uh she's
full of love and
you know just kind of fall seamlessly
into that place every time we see each
other the second season of christopher's
spin-off series law and order organized
crime is set to premiere in september
and when et spoke with the actor back in
may he opened up about why he returned
to the law and order franchise a decade
after his svu departure and he's the
long time stabler benson relationship i
can only tell you my opinion which is
as much as everybody wants what they
want when they want it i feel that there
are so many attendant issues to this
relationship
getting back on track or getting to its
new place and then
possibly possibly going to
um
different place uh whatever that means
tail i i think it's gonna require a lot
of work a lot of healing a lot that's a
complicated situation you know so uh
which i think just is gonna make both
series better and
keep interest alive in them and without
leading the audience on but i think if
we do our work correctly that something
as sacred as what this relationship what
we brought it to and then what we find
it in now with me being a recent widower
or her having had moved on and now has a
child of her own that you know let's
figure this out if this relationship
needs to go to another place
[Music]